nous procédons à la fondation d'un grand
parti souverainiste québécois
nous pouvons même devenir un peuple qui
va se tenir lui même de se sentir
capable de cette autre amérique est
d'accord c'était il ya cinquante ans le
11 octobre 1968
le congrès de fondation du parti
québécois s'ouvre à québec et le travail
à accomplir pendant ce congrès constitue
une tâche immense
guy bertrand était là il avait 30 ans à
l'époque il en a aujourd'hui 80 mais il
n'a rien oublié
c'était cet échouage tout était chaud le
général de gaulle un monde et johnson
aérienne vous avez de quoi les jeunes
être jaloux de ce qu'on a vécu à cette
époque là andré jolicoeur aussi était là
la belle impatients de construire de
bâtir d'amener l'avenir au présent
quand on est arrivé lors d'un homme qui
canaliser cette énergie là qu'on se
range au colisée suter
c'est une forêt que l'homme qui canalise
tout ça c'est évidemment rené lévesque
un an auparavant a claqué la porte du
parti libéral il ya des gens chez nous
qui en sont venus à venir tous les
partis politiques qui n'y croit
absolument pas ses envolées lyriques
contre le régime canadien galvanise les
deux mille militants qui assistent à
l'événement
nous sommes convaincus que ce régime
c'est lui avant tout qui nous a dégradé
au point de nous faire trop souvent
croupir dans l'acceptation béate ou
résignés d'une situation minoritaire
coloniale est inférieur l'euphorie parce
que rené lévesque pour nous c'était un
héros on avait une confiance aveugle en
lui parce que c'est un rassembleur
il pouvait calmer les et la calmer les
élans pas une mince tâche
car le parti québécois réunis dès le
départ des militants de tous horizons
on nous a séparés en bleu et en rouge
un premier débat éclate sur le nom à
donner au parti rené lévesque milite
pour le parti souverainiste mais les
militants votent pour la proposition de
gilles grégoire parti québécois va donc
falloir être capable de le porter ce nom
puisque nous l'avons pris monsieur
lévesque était sous l'impression que ça
donnait l'apparence qu on excluait
d'autres personnes ce timbre de faire
lui fallait que quelqu'un casse mais
très chers amis nous n'avons pas ce soir
le résultat que nous espérions
cinquante ans plus tard les péquistes
n'ont pas tout à fait le coeur à la fête
eux qui avec 17% des voix ont subi la
semaine dernière la pire défaite de leur
histoire le parti québécois redevenir
une coalition pour ce professeur
d'histoire le déroulement du congrès de
fondation nous est tout de même à mieux
comprendre le déclin actuel du parti
québécois plusieurs groupes au sein du
parti québécois ont renoncé en quelque
sorte et à taire leur différence
idéologique au nom des dépendances et se
sont mis à se chercher de nouveaux
maison politique dans laquelle ils se
retrouveraient ceux qui étaient présents
au congrès de fondation du pq croit
toujours à l'indépendance et s'interroge
sur ce que le parti québécois est devenu
parti québécois comme tel c'est terminé
sadik le nom est brûlé se sait sur un
parti qui perd tout le temps le résultat
des dernières élections
j'en fais pas un deuil mois comme elle
membre du parti québécois la marche
continue et ce n'est qu'un pas dans
cette
dans cette marche de tout un peuple
[Applaudissements]